hey cinephiles here's our list of the
top five films to see at the 2014
toronto international film festival
number five the drop gritty crime dramas
are a dime a dozen but what sets the
drop apart is the accumulated talent
involved as directed by Michael Roskam
his anticipated follow-up to bullhead
written by Dennis Lehane known for the
wire and shutter island and stars Tom
Hardy new mera paws and Mathias shown
arts it's also the final film and the
late great James Gandolfini's
incomparable career those not able to
attend the festival need only wait a
couple weeks before the drop gets a
theatrical release in select theaters
number for the world of kanako as former
detective aki kazoo searches for his
missing daughter kanako he soon learned
she has a mysterious secret life the
world of kanako is the latest film by
Tetsuya nakashima director behind
kamikaze girls memories of Mitsuko and
2010's confessions it's adapted from a
novel that many thought would be too
shocking to make into a movie thankfully
Japanese filmmakers are always willing
to challenge that notion number three
men women and children adapted from the
Chad Kultgen novel of the same name men
women and children provides a look at
the sexual frustrations that young
teenagers and adults face in today's
world the film's melancholy trailer is
replete with depictions of our
technology saturated lives and recalled
last year's criminally under scene film
disconnect with modern classics like
thank you for smoking in juneau under
his belt we're ready to see what writer
director jason reitman has to say about
our lifestyles this time around number
two Miss Julie over the course of a
midsummer night in Fermanagh in 1890 an
unsettled daughter of an anglo-irish
aristocrat encourages her father's valet
to seduce her this marks the fourth film
adaptation of the August Strindberg play
this time around it is being directed by
Liv Ullmann with a cast of just three
characters and almost entirely set in an
Irish manner we look forward to sparks
flying between two renowned thespians
Colin Farrell and Jessica Chastain
number one Nightcrawler Nightcrawler
crept up on us in July with an ingenious
marketing campaign putting star Jake
Gyllenhaal front and center as Lou bloom
a young man who stumbles upon the
underground world of freelance crime
journalism in Los Angeles gyllenhaal has
been skating from one fascinating
project to another practically his
entire career fresh off the hills of a
double punch for denis villeneuve we're
excited to see what he brings to
first-time director but established
screenwriter dan gilbert my motto is if
you want to win the lottery you have to
make the money to buy a ticket you have
to make the money to buy a ticket you
have to make the money to buy a ticket
those are our top five films to see at
this year's toronto international film
festival what movies are you most
excited for let us know in the comments
below and keep a tab open on the movie
clips in D channel for all your film
festival needs thanks for watching